i did a movie with your dad actually
it's not me not knowing that he was
great he was so nice i love hearing that
yeah imagine if you had some horror
story and you were like that was
terrible it was a nightmare
or if i had like dear dad in the
bathroom
well that's not awkward gwyneth paltrow
shocks hayley bieber with an x-rated
joke about her dad stephen baldwin we
pushed the boundary pretty far
that would be an understatement gwen had
sat down with haley for her who's in my
bathroom series on youtube thankfully
the goop founder's joke goes over well
with the model or if i had like your dad
in the bathroom i've had that happen to
me
i don't know if he even knows that i
know that but i
have had that happen i didn't i didn't
well that's good to know okay
we're just as relieved as hayley of
course her dad stephen baldwin is a
triple threat in hollywood as a producer
director and actor bravo
and gwyneth starred in the 1994 dorothy
parker biopic mrs parker and the vicious
circle and when it reflected on working
together on set i did a movie with your
dad actually
not me not knowing that well it was a
tiny independent movie i think i was
like 20 years old so it's a really long
time ago after taking a trip down memory
lane the conversation turns back to sex
except this time it's haley throwing in
her own punch line while talking about
her skin care routine i don't want to go
to bed at night unless i look like a
freshly glazed oh
okay so that's what it is okay got it
where did your head go first it went to
a like does that mean someone wants to
lick your face like it's like a food
sort of mm-hmm and then i thought like
glazed doughnut sounded like sex like a
sex thing yeah
you're like what's this new position
everybody's getting into the glazed
donut gotta love haley's sense of humor
when she isn't chatting with her pals in
her series
the model is a devoted wife to justin
bieber we have a good time together
he's just really sweet he's a good kid
he's a good part and
i love him that was just years before
haley baldwin turned mrs bieber and
legally married justin in september
2018. in fact haley's dad introduced the
two when they were just kids you met him
back in 2009
when you were 13 years old
with your dad what went down we met
because my dad he brought me to the
today show when justin performed there
so him and his mom just came over for
family dinner with me and my family look
at this and we went bowling
that's me yeah
safe to say we have mr baldwin to thank
for sparking their romance
back in 2019 justin expressed his
gratitude to his now father-in-law for
giving his blessing to mary haley the
singer posted this adorable throwback
that read quote me and the wife and the
in-laws thanks for letting your daughter
marry a savage like me both my parents
like him a lot
[Music]